Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司联手合作，在实现净零排放的道路上迈出步伐。通过投资技术和创新，每桶原油的排放量平均已经减少了22%。我们正与政府合作，创造并保护就业岗位，同时正在开发全球最大的碳捕获与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，并且在多个途径上都取得了进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的计划详情。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Reinhold sat stunned in the soft glow of his computer screen. It was approaching dawn on Tuesday, July 9, 2002 and the 23-year-old medical student had been up all night on the internet. What he had witnessed had disturbed him measurably and Reinhold had to tell somebody. He opened up a new email template and began typing. Ladies and gentlemen of the Federal Criminal Bureau, my name is Reinhold.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人不安的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用上或我们网站上本集节目的说明。莱因霍尔德坐在电脑屏幕柔和的光线下，感到震惊。那是2002年7月9日星期二的黎明前夕，这位23岁的医学生整晚都在上网。他所目睹的一切让他感到极度不安，莱因霍尔德必须告诉某人。他打开一个新的电子邮件模板，开始打字。联邦刑事局的各位先生女士，我叫莱因霍尔德。
He went on to describe his experiences online the night before. Seeking horrifying thrills, Reinhold had used widely popular search engines to explore the darkest recesses of the internet for content that would shock him. They led him to a forum where a small but active group of users interacted excitedly over their shared interests in taboo and all forbidden fetishes. Reinhold thought that what he was reading was just erotic roleplay based entirely in fantasy. His attention was soon drawn to an advertisement posted by a user named Frankie. Titled, Boys Sort for Butchering, the accompanying text read, Hi, I'm Frankie from Germany. I'm looking for young men between 18 and 30 to butcher. If you have a normal build, then come to me. I'll butcher you and eat your delicious flesh.
他接着描述了前一天晚上他在网上的经历。为了寻求恐怖的刺激，莱因霍尔德使用广受欢迎的搜索引擎探索互联网最黑暗的角落，寻找那些会让他感到震惊的内容。这些搜索将他带到了一个论坛，那里有一小群活跃的用户正兴奋地交流着他们对禁忌和各种被禁止的恋物癖的共同兴趣。莱因霍尔德以为他所读到的只是完全基于幻想的色情角色扮演。他的注意力很快被一个名叫弗兰基的用户发布的广告所吸引。标题为“寻找男孩进行屠宰”，随附的文字写道：“嗨，我是来自德国的弗兰基。我正在寻找18到30岁的年轻男性进行屠宰。如果你身材正常，那就来找我吧。我会屠宰你，并吃掉你美味的肉。”
Driven by curiosity, Reinhold sent Frankie an email. In it, he mentioned his age and that he lived in the Austrian town of Innsbruck. How many boys have you butchered and eaten Reinhold tight before clicking sand? He received a prompt response. Well, let's say I have experience, Frankie wrote back. In any case, you wouldn't be the first. Reinhold continued reading the email from Frankie. In reference to Reinhold's age of 23, Frankie had written,
出于好奇，莱因霍尔德给弗兰基发了一封电子邮件。在邮件中，他提到了自己的年龄，并说他住在奥地利因斯布鲁克镇。在点击发送之前，莱因霍尔德打字问道：“你屠宰并吃掉了多少个男孩？”他很快收到了回复。“嗯，可以说我有经验，”弗兰基回信道。“无论如何，你不会是第一个。”莱因霍尔德继续阅读弗兰基的邮件。针对莱因霍尔德23岁的年龄，弗兰基写道：
That's an optimal butchering age. The body has just matured and is still very tender. He requested that Reinhold tell him more about himself, specifically his height and weight, Before signing off his email with, Your master butcher, Frankie. Reinhold was shocked. The lines I have experienced and you wouldn't be the first, implied Frankie wasn't just pretending. Wanting no part in what he had planned, Reinhold replied, I don't want to be butchered, I want to live.
“那是最佳的屠宰年龄。身体刚刚成熟，而且还非常鲜嫩。”他要求莱因霍尔德多告诉他一些关于自己的信息，特别是身高和体重，然后在邮件末尾签上了：“你的屠夫大师，弗兰基。”莱因霍尔德感到震惊。“我有经验”和“你不会是第一个”这些话暗示弗兰基不仅仅是在假装。莱因霍尔德不想参与他计划的事情，于是回复道：“我不想被屠宰，我想活下去。”
He then asked Frankie what compels someone to kill and eat other people. The question is as old as humanity itself, Frankie answered. For myself, I'm not interested in killing someone in cold blood, Because then I would be simply grabbing somebody and eating him, and I would be just a common killer. I'm looking for people who have a desire to die, for whatever reason. Some of them dream of being butchered, others simply want to end their lives because they have no future prospects. I then prepare for them a death such as they desire for themselves. My wish since childhood has been to have someone entirely to myself and then to absorb him into me by eating him.
然后他问弗兰基是什么驱使一个人去杀害并吃掉他人。“这个问题和人类本身一样古老，”弗兰基回答道。“对我来说，我没兴趣冷血地杀人，因为那样我只是随便抓个人吃掉，那我就是一个普通的杀手。我寻找的是那些有死亡愿望的人，无论出于什么原因。他们中有些人梦想被屠宰，另一些人只是因为没有未来而想结束生命。我为他们准备了他们所渴望的死亡。我从童年起的愿望就是拥有一个完全属于我的人，然后通过吃掉他将他融入我的体内。”
Reinhold's response was swift and blunt. You are not doing these people any favor by killing them. You look exclusively for young men and exploit someone's life crisis. Everyone sometimes reaches a point where he can't cope with life. Sometimes they have no friends and no family and no one they can talk with. No, what you do is not admirable, but pathologically perverted. People who come to you and whose fate you seal would have done better to go to a psychologist. And you too should go to a psychologist, for even if you won't admit it to yourself, you are a cold-blooded murderer.
莱因霍尔德的回复迅速而直率。“你杀掉这些人并不是在帮他们。你专门寻找年轻男性，利用了别人的生活危机。每个人有时都会达到无法应对生活的地步。有时他们没有朋友，没有家人，也没有可以倾诉的人。不，你的所作所为并不令人钦佩，而是病态的变态。那些来到你这里、命运被你封死的人，本该去看心理医生。你也应该去看心理医生，因为即使你不愿承认，你也是一个冷血的杀人犯。”
By the time their correspondence had ended, the sun was beginning to rise. Reinhold had spent a sleepless night glued to his computer, emailing back and forth with Frankie. Concerned by what he had uncovered, he reached out to Germany's Federal Criminal Bureau via email. After detailing his interactions with Frankie, Reinhold ended his email by stating, I don't know how to handle it. At 5.49am, Reinhold clicked sand. It took 19 days before anyone at the Bureau addressed Reinhold's email. A chief criminal commissioner eventually looked into the matter by going undercover online and contacting Frankie directly.
当他们的通信结束时，太阳已经开始升起。莱因霍尔德度过了一个不眠之夜，一直盯着电脑，与弗兰基来回发邮件。出于对他所发现内容的担忧，他通过电子邮件联系了德国联邦刑事局。在详细说明了他与弗兰基的互动后，莱因霍尔德在邮件结尾写道：“我不知道该怎么处理这件事。”凌晨5点49分，莱因霍尔德点击了发送。联邦刑事局过了19天才有人处理莱因霍尔德的邮件。一位刑事总督察最终通过在线卧底并直接联系弗兰基调查了此事。
Feigning interest in the topic of cannibalism, they emailed Frankie to obtain information that might lead to his real-world identity. The message read, I stumbled on your post where you're looking for boys to butcher. I find it fascinating. Please write to me about how you imagine it. Frankie sent a long and detailed reply later that night that began. Now, as I say it, you will come to me, live with me for a week, and during that time, I'll really get to know you. One wants to know whom one is eating. Frankie then explained that during the final two days of their encounter,
他们假装对食人话题感兴趣，给弗兰基发邮件以获取可能导致其现实身份的信息。信息写道：“我偶然发现了你寻找男孩进行屠宰的帖子。我觉得这很迷人。请写信告诉我你是如何想象这个过程的。”弗兰基当晚晚些时候发来了一封长而详细的回复，开头写道：“现在，既然我说了，你就会来找我，和我住上一周，在那段时间里，我会真正了解你。一个人总想知道自己吃的是谁。”弗兰基随后解释说，在他们相处的最后两天，
he would place his victim on a liquid diet to keep their intestines empty for the butchering process. That would begin on the last day, or day X, as Frankie called it. He'd wake his victim early, wash and shave them in the bathroom, then take them to his slaughter room. He offered to kill the undercover commissioner in whatever way they'd like, fully conscious or drugged. Their choice. I'll carve you up to prepare many delightful dishes from your delicious flesh, Frankie told the commissioner, who he thought was a 26-year-old that lived in the German state of Hesse. Incidentally, Frankie wrote, I am also from Hesse, near Castle. He ended the email as he had with Reinhold weeks prior.
他会让受害者进行流质饮食，以保持肠道排空，以便进行屠宰过程。那将从最后一天，即弗兰基所说的“X日”开始。他会早早叫醒受害者，在浴室里为他们清洗和剃毛，然后带他们去他的屠宰室。他提出以受害者喜欢的任何方式杀掉这位卧底督察，无论是完全清醒还是被下药。由他们选择。“我会把你切开，用你美味的肉准备许多美味的菜肴，”弗兰基告诉那位督察，他以为对方是一个住在德国黑森州、26岁的年轻人。顺便说一句，弗兰基写道：“我也来自黑森州，靠近卡塞尔。”他像几周前对莱因霍尔德那样结束了这封邮件。
Your master butcher, Frankie. At this point, there was nothing to prove that Frankie had killed or devoured anyone. With no evidence of a crime having taken place, the Federal Criminal Bureau cast the case aside. What he spoke of was so outrageous and inconceivable, it was easy to believe that he was just some imaginative deviant dramatizing his gruesome and violent kink online. But Reinhold felt otherwise. He remained convinced that he had interacted with a real-world killer. Five months after his interactions with Frankie and upon realizing authorities were no longer pursuing the matter, Reinhold filed a criminal complaint for the suspicion of murder. He addressed how the accused had expressed experience in the field of cannibalism, which gave Reinhold the well-founded suspicion that, at least in one case, he had killed a person. It took another 44 days before any further action was taken.
“你的屠夫大师，弗兰基。”此时，没有任何证据表明弗兰基杀害或吞食了任何人。由于没有犯罪发生的证据，联邦刑事局将此案搁置了。他所说的话如此离谱且不可思议，人们很容易相信他只是一个富有想象力的变态，在网上演绎他那令人毛骨悚然的暴力癖好。但莱因霍尔德不这么认为。他坚信自己与一个现实中的杀手进行了互动。在与弗兰基互动五个月后，意识到当局不再追究此事，莱因霍尔德以涉嫌谋杀为由提出了刑事控告。他提到了被告如何表达在食人领域的经验，这给了莱因霍尔德充分的怀疑理由，即至少在一个案例中，他杀害了一个人。又过了44天，才采取了进一步行动。
By now, the Bureau had obtained Frankie's internet provider address. This allowed them to locate the computer where he sent his emails, as well as the device's internet service customer information. The computer was pinpointed to a residential address in the medieval town of Roltenborg in Hesse. Specifically in the hamlet of Wusterfeld. The internet service it used was contracted to a Mr. Armin Mivus. The suspicion of murder complaint filed by Reinhold was delegated to the District Court of Roltenborg. Even though Reinhold's accusations were based solely on text on the internet, the court ruled that Frankie's online confessions constituted suspicion of presentation of violence. This was enough for them to issue a search warrant for the Wusterfeld address where Frankie had sent his emails.
此时，联邦刑事局已经获得了弗兰基的互联网服务提供商地址。这使他们能够定位他发送电子邮件的电脑，以及该设备的互联网服务客户信息。这台电脑被锁定在黑森州罗滕堡中世纪小镇的一个住宅地址。具体来说是在伍斯特费尔德村。其使用的互联网服务签约人为阿明·迈维斯先生。莱因霍尔德提出的涉嫌谋杀控告被移交给了罗滕堡地方法院。尽管莱因霍尔德的指控仅基于互联网上的文字，但法院裁定弗兰基的在线供述构成了“展示暴力”的嫌疑。这足以让他们对弗兰基发送电子邮件的伍斯特费尔德地址签发搜查令。
The three-story, 36-room, Tudor-style Wusterfeld home was an impressive residence, but it had seen better days. Built in the Middle Ages, around 900 AD, the manor sat on a 3,000 square meter plot of land of mostly meadows, with an outbuilding that was previously used as a stable. Its half-timbered facade looked slightly askew, as the doors, windows and dormers were positioned without any sense of symmetry. The property was owned by the Mivus family who had purchased the decrepit manor with the intention of renovating it into a functioning boarding house. Having failed that, the manor had been permanently stuck in an unfinished, worsening state. Of the five family members who had settled in the home, only one remained. The front iron gate was open when the police arrived at the Wusterfeld manor on the morning of Tuesday, December 10, 2002. They made their way up the gravel drive, and upon reaching the house, banged the bronze lion's head knocker on the front door.
这座三层楼、36个房间、都铎风格的伍斯特费尔德住宅是一处令人印象深刻的住所，但它已经风光不再。这座庄园建于中世纪，大约公元900年，坐落在一块3000平方米的土地上，大部分是草地，还有一个以前用作马厩的附属建筑。其半木结构的立面看起来有些歪斜，因为门、窗和天窗的布置毫无对称感。该房产由迈维斯家族拥有，他们购买这座破旧的庄园是打算将其翻修为一家功能齐全的寄宿公寓。由于未能实现，庄园一直处于未完工且日益恶化的状态。在搬进家里的五名家庭成员中，只剩下一个人。2002年12月10日星期二上午，当警察到达伍斯特费尔德庄园时，前铁门是开着的。他们沿着碎石车道走上去，到达房子后，敲响了前门上的青铜狮头门环。
A tall, lean man with thinning dark blonde hair and pale eyes soon appeared. It was the sole homeowner-occupier, 41-year-old Armin Mivus. He was in the process of getting ready for work and was surprised to see the officers, who handed him their search warrant. The inside of the house was dark and musky. Dust covered almost every surface, wallpaper was peeling, the carpets were stained, cobwebs hung from the walls, and dead rodents were spotted in the corners. Most rooms were filled to the ceiling with furniture, appliances, clothing, and or computing equipment. Some were so crammed with junk that the officers couldn't even get into them. The bathrooms were equally filthy.
一个身材高大、瘦削，头发稀疏、呈深金黄色，眼睛苍白的男人很快出现了。他就是唯一的房主兼住户，41岁的阿明·迈维斯。他当时正准备去上班，看到警察感到很惊讶，警察将搜查令递给了他。房子内部阴暗且有霉味。几乎每个表面都覆盖着灰尘，墙纸剥落，地毯上有污渍，墙上挂着蜘蛛网，角落里还能看到死掉的啮齿动物。大多数房间里堆满了家具、电器、衣服和/或电脑设备。有些房间堆满了垃圾，警察甚至无法进入。浴室也同样肮脏。
Only a few rooms appeared lived in and semi-maintained, including a kitchen, dining room, and two computer work rooms that contained a plethora of tech equipment, including a large collection of videotapes and computer discs. On the top floor of the building was a traditional smoke room once used to store and cure meat and fish. Little remained from when the room was used in this manner, aside from an old oil stove and a thick layer of soot that covered the walls. The metal frame of a single bed had since been brought in and was rusting in one corner of the room. Against the back wall was a large wooden cross in the shape of an axe, and in the center was a long table adorned with three knives, a meat cleaver, and an axe. A butcher's apron also lay nearby. Patches of a dark red substance stained the concrete floor. In a kitchen downstairs was a freezer that at first glance held nothing more than a few frozen pizzas.
只有少数几个房间看起来有人居住并经过半维护，包括厨房、餐厅和两个电脑工作间，里面有大量的技术设备，包括大量的录像带和电脑光盘。建筑的顶层是一个传统的熏制室，曾经用于储存和腌制肉类和鱼类。除了一个旧油炉和覆盖墙壁的一层厚厚的煤灰外，房间里几乎没有留下什么东西。一张单人床的金属框架后来被搬了进来，在一个角落里生锈。后墙上是一个巨大的斧头形状的木十字架，中间是一张长桌，上面摆放着三把刀、一把切肉刀和一把斧头。附近还放着一件屠夫围裙。混凝土的地板上沾着几块深红色的物质。楼下的厨房里有一个冰柜，乍一看里面只有几块冷冻披萨。
Upon closer inspection, an officer noticed the freezer had a false bottom. When she lifted it up, she uncovered large amounts of meat stored in several bags, some of it minced and some cut into steaks. The police officer held the bags up to Armin Marvis and asked him what they were. Wild pig meat, he answered. She looked at him incredulously. She did a lot of cooking and the meat looked like nothing she had ever seen before. The bags were labelled with the word Kator. Hello Kator, the email began.
仔细检查后，一名警官注意到冰柜有一个假底。当她掀开它时，发现了储存在几个袋子里的大量肉，有些是绞碎的，有些切成了牛排。警察拿着袋子给阿明·迈维斯看，问他那是什么。他回答说：“野猪肉。”她怀疑地看着他。她经常做饭，这种肉看起来不像她以前见过的任何东西。袋子上贴着“卡托尔”这个词。邮件开头写道：“你好，卡托尔。”
I read your ad. I'll slaughter you, but only if you really want me to. Let me hear from you. Your master butcher, Frankie. It was Monday, February 5, 2001, and Frankie had just stumbled across an ad on one of the online cannibal forums he frequented. Titled Your Dinner, a user going by the name Kator had written, I offer to let myself be eaten alive. Kator was pleased to receive Frankie's offer. I hope you're really serious about it, he emailed back. I really want it and have already met enough cyber cannibals. Frankie had experienced similar disappointment.
“我读了你的广告。我会屠宰你，但前提是你真的想要我这样做。让我听到你的消息。你的屠夫大师，弗兰基。”那是2001年2月5日星期一，弗兰基刚刚偶然发现了他经常光顾的在线食人论坛上的一个广告。标题为“你的晚餐”，一个名叫卡托尔的用户写道：“我提议让自己被活活吃掉。”卡托尔很高兴收到弗兰基的提议。“我希望你是认真的，”他回信道。“我真的很想要这样，而且已经见过足够多的网络食人者了。”弗兰基也经历过类似的失望。
Several men had expressed eagerness for him to eat them online, only to back out once they met in person. Unlike them, Kator was committed. He was very clear about his expectations, telling Frankie that he wanted his genitals to be bitten off. Then, I'll be ready for slaughter, he declared. The pair settled on a date. On the ninth day in the following month of March, Frankie would eat Kator. The act would take place at Frankie's home, in a sound-proofed room he had designed for this sole purpose. As March drew nearer, the frequency in which Kator and Frankie communicated online increased, as did their level of excitement.
有几个人在网上表达了让他吃掉他们的渴望，但一旦见面就退缩了。与他们不同，卡托尔是坚定的。他非常清楚自己的期望，告诉弗兰基他希望自己的生殖器被咬掉。“然后，我就准备好被屠宰了，”他宣称。两人定下了日期。在接下来的3月9日，弗兰基将吃掉卡托尔。这一行为将在弗兰基的家中进行，在一个他专门为此设计的隔音房间里。随着3月的临近，卡托尔和弗兰基在网上交流的频率增加了，他们的兴奋程度也随之提高。
They showed little interest in talking about the mundane parts of their lives, such as their jobs or relationships. Instead, almost every night, they chatted excessively about the upcoming slaughter in gory and sexually explicit detail. Offline, neither man spoke a word of what they had planned to anyone. No one among their family, friends or colleagues even knew of their forbidden sexual fetish. They had become masters at living a double life. In reality, both men lived unassuming lives and worked in the tech sector. Frankie was considered a nice fellow who mowed his neighbour's lawns without payment and happily watched his friends' children. Kator dutifully looked after his grandmother and paid the bills for friends who were struggling with money.
他们对谈论生活中平凡的部分，如工作或人际关系，表现出很少的兴趣。相反，几乎每天晚上，他们都会过度地谈论即将到来的屠宰，细节血腥且露骨。在现实生活中，两人都没有向任何人透露他们计划的事情。他们的家人、朋友或同事中没有人知道他们这种被禁止的性癖好。他们已经成为了过双重生活的大师。实际上，这两个人都过着谦逊的生活，在科技行业工作。弗兰基被认为是一个好人，他免费为邻居修剪草坪，并乐于照顾朋友的孩子。卡托尔尽职尽责地照顾他的祖母，并为那些经济困难的朋友支付账单。
Both men were known to have an avid interest in computers, though they only logged into the cannibal forums when those around them were asleep. As to how Frankie and Kator came about, the paths were different, but the destination was the same. The man behind the username Frankie felt his cannibalistic urge to develop as a child and it turned sexual by the time he was a teenager. The underlying cause was abandonment issues. In his own words, his goal was to bind to someone in a way that they would always be with him and to fill the hollow, empty feeling he had inside. For the man behind the username Kator, the longing to be eaten coincided with puberty. A masochist, Kator derived sexual gratification from his own pain or humiliation. As an adult, he had explored this side of himself consensually with sex workers, but none were willing to eat him like he wanted.
众所周知，这两个人都对电脑有浓厚的兴趣，尽管他们只有在周围人睡着时才会登录食人论坛。至于弗兰基和卡托尔是如何走到一起的，路径不同，但目的地相同。用户名“弗兰基”背后的男人感到他的食人冲动在童年时期就开始发展，并在十几岁时变成了性冲动。根本原因是遗弃问题。用他自己的话说，他的目标是以一种他们永远和他在一起的方式与某人结合，并填补他内心空虚、空洞的感觉。对于用户名“卡托尔”背后的男人来说，被吃掉的渴望与青春期同时出现。作为一个受虐狂，卡托尔从自己的痛苦或羞辱中获得性满足。作为成年人，他曾与性工作者自愿探索过这一面，但没有人愿意像他想要的那样吃掉他。
The desire has lasted a long time, Kator wrote to Frankie, and will last until it finally comes true. 28 hours before the slaughter was scheduled to take place, Kator and Frankie messaged each other for the final time. They tied up the loose ends of their plan, including what would become of Kator's quote, unprocessed fleshy parts, like his tendons, skin, organs and bones. Giddy with excitement for their meeting, Kator ended their communications by typing, I'll bring myself as breakfast. Frankie replied, I'll have an appetite. It was a drizzly winter morning on Friday, March 9, 2001, as Frankie stood on a platform at the Castle Wilhelmsfuhr train station.
“这种渴望持续了很长时间，”卡托尔写信给弗兰基，“并将持续到它最终实现为止。”在屠宰计划进行前28小时，卡托尔和弗兰基进行了最后一次交流。他们敲定了计划的细节，包括卡托尔所谓的“未加工的肉质部分”，如肌腱、皮肤、器官和骨头。卡托尔对他们的会面感到兴奋不已，他在结束交流时打字道：“我会把自己作为早餐带去。”弗兰基回复道：“我会胃口大开的。”2001年3月9日星期五，这是一个细雨蒙蒙的冬日早晨，弗兰基站在卡塞尔威廉斯富尔火车站的站台上。
The 10-14 train arrived and Frankie's attention was drawn to one of the first passengers to disembark. He was a slender man of average height with grey-green eyes. He was wearing dark clothing and a baseball cap, which partially hid his streaked grey and balding black hair. It was Kator. The men recognized each other immediately from the photos they had traded online. They exchanged a brief hello. Let's get off the platform, Kator said. There are too many people around. Frankie led him to a nearby lot where he had parked his car.
10点14分的火车到达了，弗兰基的注意力被第一批下车的乘客之一吸引住了。他是一个身材苗条、中等身高的男人，有着灰绿色的眼睛。他穿着深色衣服，戴着棒球帽，部分遮住了他灰白相间、秃顶的黑发。那是卡托尔。两人立刻从他们在网上交换的照片中认出了对方。他们简短地打了声招呼。“离开站台吧，”卡托尔说。“周围人太多了。”弗兰基带他去了附近的一个停车场，他把车停在那里。
Driving away from Castle City, Frankie tried to keep his focus on the road, but Kator started caressing him from the passenger seat. Stop it, Frankie told him. Wait until we're in my home. It's only 60 kilometers. They arrived in Wusterfeld an hour later. Frankie pulled up to his expansive, though severely neglected manner, and the two headed inside. Upon returning from the kitchen with coffee, Frankie was confronted by a stark-naked Kator, who said, I want you to be able to admire your food. Within minutes he was ready to get started. Come on, show me the room, he demanded.
开车离开卡塞尔市时，弗兰基试图将注意力集中在路上，但卡托尔开始在副驾驶座上抚摸他。“停下，”弗兰基告诉他。“等我们到了我家再说。只有60公里。”一小时后，他们到达了伍斯特费尔德。弗兰基把车开到他那宽敞但严重荒废的庄园前，两人走了进去。从厨房端着咖啡回来后，弗兰基面对的是赤身裸体的卡托尔，他说：“我希望你能欣赏你的食物。”几分钟内，他准备开始了。“来吧，带我去看房间，”他要求道。
Frankie then led him upstairs to his slaughter room. Inside, Kator remained in a heightened state of arousal. He ordered Frankie to tear the flesh off his body with his teeth, but Frankie was reluctant. This was not how he envisioned their encounter. Firstly, he hated violence. Secondly, he expected it to be a week-long affair, allowing time for the men to get to know each other before any blood was spilled. The slaughter process wasn't supposed to be frenzied, it was meant to be slow and methodical. Kator's vision was far more spontaneous and savage. He wanted to die that very day.
弗兰基随后带他上楼去了他的屠宰室。在里面，卡托尔保持着高度的兴奋状态。他命令弗兰基用牙齿撕下他身上的肉，但弗兰基很不情愿。这不是他设想的会面方式。首先，他讨厌暴力。其次，他预计这将是一场为期一周的交往，让两人在流血前有时间互相了解。屠宰过程不应该是疯狂的，它应该是缓慢而有条理的。卡托尔的愿景要自发和野蛮得多。他想在那一天就死。
Unable to go through with Kator's demands, Frankie left him disappointed. You're too soft, Kator remarked. You can't inflict pain the way I'd like it. You can't slaughter me at all. He asked to be taken back to the train station. The men hardly spoke during the drive. Once they reached the station, Frankie apologised. He reiterated that it was his life's wish to consume someone, but they wanted different things from their experience. It just wasn't going to work. Kator purchased a train ticket intent on going home, then suddenly he had a change of heart. If I go back to Berlin now, I'll be facing a showdown, he said.
无法满足卡托尔的要求，弗兰基让他感到失望。“你太软弱了，”卡托尔评论道。“你无法像我想要的那样施加痛苦。你根本无法屠宰我。”他要求被送回火车站。开车时两人几乎没说话。到达车站后，弗兰基道歉了。他重申，吃掉某人是他一生的愿望，但他们对这次经历有不同的要求。这行不通。卡托尔买了张火车票打算回家，突然他改变了主意。“如果我现在回柏林，我将面临摊牌，”他说。
While Frankie didn't know what that meant, whatever was playing on Kator's mind had led him to compromise. He still wanted to die that day, but he was willing to prolong the experience and scale back the violence. Frankie would no longer have to literally eat him alive, though he still wanted his genitals to be removed. Kator came up with a new plan. He would be drugged, then once he was drowsy enough, Frankie could go through with a far more intricate slaughter. Frankie was glad Kator had reconsidered and headed to a nearby pharmacy where he purchased liquid cold medicine and sleeping pills. Kator took ten of the pills and washed it down with the entire bottle of cold medicine. The potent combination took effect on the drive back to Wusterfeld. The two men returned to the slaughter room. Kator removed his clothes, laid on the bed in the corner and guzzled down half a bottle of schnapps to become tipsy as well as drowsy.
虽然弗兰基不知道那意味着什么，但卡托尔脑子里想的任何事情都导致他做出了妥协。他仍然想在那天死，但他愿意延长体验并减少暴力。弗兰基不再需要真的把他活活吃掉，尽管他仍然希望切除他的生殖器。卡托尔想出了一个新计划。他会被下药，然后一旦他足够昏昏欲睡，弗兰基就可以进行更复杂的屠宰。弗兰基很高兴卡托尔重新考虑了，于是前往附近的一家药店，购买了液体感冒药和安眠药。卡托尔吃了十片药，并用整瓶感冒药送服。这种强效组合在开车回伍斯特费尔德的路上生效了。两人回到了屠宰室。卡托尔脱掉衣服，躺在角落的床上，灌下半瓶杜松子酒，变得既醉又昏昏欲睡。
By now, it was just past 6pm. I can't stand it any longer, Kator barked. Do it. Now. Cutting off Kator's penis was a painful and messy process as the initial knife used was found to be too blunt. It took several slashes of a larger sharper knife to completely sever the organ from Kator's body, all the while he screamed in agony. Though once it had been removed, Kator was astonished and thrilled, and within minutes he reported feeling no pain at all. He sought to eat the organ, but the raw flesh was too tough to bite into. After patching up Kator's wound, Frankie headed down to the kitchen where he proceeded to blanch and broil the organ in two halves. He seasoned the halves and served them on a plate with fresh tomatoes.
此时，刚过下午6点。“我再也受不了了，”卡托尔大喊。“做吧。现在。”切掉卡托尔的阴茎是一个痛苦且混乱的过程，因为最初使用的刀被发现太钝了。用了几下更大更锋利的刀才完全将器官从卡托尔的身体上切下，整个过程中他痛苦地尖叫。虽然一旦切除，卡托尔感到惊讶和兴奋，几分钟内他报告说一点也不疼了。他试图吃掉那个器官，但生肉太硬，咬不动。在处理好卡托尔的伤口后，弗兰基下到厨房，将器官切成两半进行焯水和煎烤。他给两半调了味，并配上新鲜番茄装在盘子里端了上来。
By the time he returned to the slaughter room, the mattress beneath Kator was soaked in blood. Kator attempted to eat the cooked flesh, but it was rock hard. Not even a fork could penetrate it. Deeming it inedible, Frankie threw the pieces into a bucket as waste. Kator laid back on the bed, disappointed. All he wanted to do now was sleep. Frankie stroked his face to soothe him. Before Kator drifted off, the pair finally revealed to each other their real names. Up until this point, they had only known and referred to each other by their online usernames from the cannibal forums. I'm Armin, Frankie said.
当他回到屠宰室时，卡托尔身下的床垫被血浸透了。卡托尔试图吃掉煮熟的肉，但它坚硬如石。连叉子都插不进去。弗兰基认为它无法食用，便把碎片扔进桶里作为废物。卡托尔失望地躺回床上。他现在只想睡觉。弗兰基抚摸他的脸来安抚他。在卡托尔昏昏欲睡之前，两人终于向对方透露了真实姓名。直到这一点，他们只知道并以食人论坛上的在线用户名来称呼对方。“我是阿明，”弗兰基说。
Decades before police came knocking on his door, an eight-year-old Armin Mivus wondered his family's Wusterfeld manner feeling incredibly lonely. His mother, Veltraud Mivus, had moved Armin and his two older half-brothers to the expensive property shortly after Armin's father had abandoned them to pursue a relationship with his girlfriend. Armin had loved his father, but when he ran desperately after his father's car, howling for him not to leave, his father didn't even glance at the rearview mirror. Armin despised him after that. Armin's brothers didn't stick around long either. They moved out, leaving Armin alone with his mother. To Veltraud Mivus, men were not independent individuals with their own interests and needs. They were malleable things that she could shape and control. Once his father and brothers were gone, Armin was the only man left in Veltraud's life, and she began to shape him accordingly. Veltraud didn't do any housework, so the extensive upkeep of the manor fell to Armin.
在警察敲门几十年前，八岁的阿明·迈维斯在家里伍斯特费尔德庄园徘徊，感到无比孤独。他的母亲维尔特劳德·迈维斯在阿明的父亲抛弃他们去追求他的女朋友后不久，就带着阿明和他的两个同母异父的哥哥搬到了这处昂贵的房产。阿明爱他的父亲，但当他绝望地追着父亲的车，嚎叫着让他不要离开时，父亲甚至没有看一眼后视镜。从那以后，阿明鄙视他。阿明的哥哥们也没待多久。他们搬走了，留下阿明和母亲在一起。对维尔特劳德·迈维斯来说，男人不是有自己兴趣和需求的独立个体。他们是可以塑造和控制的可塑之物。父亲和哥哥们走后，阿明是维尔特劳德生活中剩下的唯一男人，她开始相应地塑造他。维尔特劳德不做任何家务，所以庄园繁重的维护工作落在了阿明身上。
Referring to him as her little servant, Veltraud ordered Armin around the home, expecting him to cook and clean when he wasn't at school. When he was, Armin was teased for his relationship with his domineering mother. Other students called him a mother's boy and made fun of the traditional leaderhosen he wore at her insistence. In the aftermath of her failed marriage, Veltraud withdrew from society, fearing further rejection. This fear led her to foster a sheltered and oppressive life for Armin, at times sabotaging his relationships with others so he'd only have her. She had him live in the room across from her own and would summon him by banging the end of her walking stick on the hard floor. Despite going to great lengths to keep Armin in her life, Veltraud was very rarely affectionate towards him. She treated Armin downright coolly, with the amount of times she hugged him each year countable on a single hand.
维尔特劳德称他为“我的小仆人”，在家里对阿明发号施令，期望他在不在学校时做饭和打扫卫生。在学校时，阿明因为与专横母亲的关系而受到嘲笑。其他学生叫他“妈宝”，并取笑他在她坚持下穿的传统皮裤。在失败的婚姻之后，维尔特劳德退出了社会，害怕进一步的拒绝。这种恐惧导致她为阿明营造了一种受保护且压抑的生活，有时甚至破坏他与他人的关系，这样他就只能拥有她。她让他住在她房间对面，并通过用手杖末端敲击坚硬的地板来召唤他。尽管为了让阿明留在她身边付出了巨大努力，维尔特劳德却很少对他表现出亲情。她对阿明非常冷淡，她每年拥抱他的次数一只手就能数过来。
Veltraud also feigned illness as a means to control. One day, a 15-year-old Armin was helping his mother get downstairs after she had complained of leg pain. He thought to himself, one good shove and it's finally over. Instead of unleashing his rage, Armin internalized it. He hated his own cowardice and how his devotion and eagerness to please overrode his ability to express his true feelings. The problem was, even though his mother was a burden, she was the last meaningful person in his life. Armin feared losing her and he suspected she felt the same about him. Still, she couldn't feel the place of the male role model that Armin desperately sought.
维尔特劳德还假装生病作为控制手段。有一天，15岁的阿明在母亲抱怨腿痛后帮她下楼。他心想：“只要推一下，一切就结束了。”阿明没有释放他的愤怒，而是将其内化了。他讨厌自己的懦弱，以及他的奉献和取悦的渴望如何压倒了他表达真实感受的能力。问题是，尽管他的母亲是一个负担，但她是阿明生活中最后一个有意义的人。阿明害怕失去她，他怀疑她对他也有同样的感觉。尽管如此，她无法填补阿明迫切寻求的男性榜样位置。
From a young age, Armin relied on his imagination to escape his reality. He would lose himself in books with the dark fairy tales written by German brothers Jacob and Wilhelm Grimm becoming treasured fantasy worlds he could revisit over and over. Some days, Armin would track the mountainous countryside at the rear of his home with a brother's grim book in hand, looking for somewhere to read in private. On one such occasion, a ten-year-old Armin sat beneath a tree and opened his book to his favorite fairy tale, Hansel and Gretel. One of the most popular stories in the brother's grim collection, the narrative follows two children lost in a forest. Eventually, they stumble across a house made of gingerbread with an old woman inside who promises to help them. She is actually an evil witch who captures Hansel and Gretel. Armin would have a physical reaction whenever he read this story.
从很小的时候起，阿明就依靠想象力来逃避现实。他会沉浸在书中，德国雅各布·格林和威廉·格林兄弟撰写的黑暗童话成为他可以反复重温的珍贵幻想世界。有时，阿明会带着格林兄弟的书在自家后方的山区乡村漫步，寻找可以私下阅读的地方。有一次，10岁的阿明坐在树下，打开书翻到他最喜欢的童话故事《汉赛尔与格莱特》。作为格林兄弟收藏中最受欢迎的故事之一，叙述跟随两个在森林中迷路的孩子。最终，他们偶然发现了一座由姜饼制成的房子，里面有一个承诺帮助他们的老妇人。她实际上是一个邪恶的女巫，抓住了汉赛尔和格莱特。每当阿明读到这个故事时，他都会有生理反应。
His heart rate would increase, with each page turned bringing him closer to the part that truly delighted him. The old woman had only pretended to be so kind. She was in reality a wicked witch. Armin would read with excitement. When a child fell into her power, she killed it, cooked it, and ate it, and that was a feast day with her. Early in the morning before the children were awake, she was already up, and when she saw both of them sleeping and looking so pretty with their plump and rosy cheeks, she muttered to herself, that will be a dainty mouthful. Armin considered how lovely it would be to read another person. In doing so, they would assimilate into him, and he would never again feel the hollow sting of loneliness. As these thoughts fermented in the privacy of Armin's mind, he sought the opinion of the only person he could trust, an imaginary brother he had formed in response to the overwhelming isolation he experienced. Armin had given his imaginary brother the name Frankie.
他的心率会加快，每一页的翻动都让他更接近那个真正让他愉悦的部分。老妇人只是假装很善良。她实际上是一个邪恶的女巫。阿明兴奋地读着。“当一个孩子落入她的权力范围时，她就杀掉它、煮熟它、吃掉它，那对她来说是一个盛宴日。清晨在孩子们醒来之前，她就已经起床了，当她看到他们两个睡着，脸蛋圆润红润，看起来那么漂亮时，她喃喃自语道：‘那将是一口美味。’”阿明思考着阅读另一个人会是多么可爱。通过这样做，他们将融入他，他将永远不会再感到孤独的空洞刺痛。当这些想法在阿明私密的头脑中发酵时，他寻求了唯一可以信任的人的意见，一个他在经历压倒性孤立后形成的虚构兄弟。阿明给他的虚构兄弟取名为弗兰基。
Decades later, Rottenborg police left Armin's house after executing a search warrant. They didn't leave empty-handed. They had confiscated his computer equipment, among other things, and a book of his titled Flesh and Blood. Most significant was the three bags of meat they had taken from his freezer. Once the police were gone, Armin Mivus paced nervously, wanting someone to talk to. He couldn't speak with his mother, as she had died several years prior from a heart attack. Armin had lived alone in the house since. He picked up the phone and called one of his half-brothers. His sister-in-law picked up and immediately sensed something was wrong.
几十年后，罗滕堡警方在执行搜查令后离开了阿明的家。他们没有空手而归。他们没收了他的电脑设备以及其他物品，还有一本他题为《血肉》的书。最重要的是他们从冰柜里带走的三袋肉。警察走后，阿明·迈维斯紧张地踱步，想找人说话。他无法与母亲交谈，因为她几年前因心脏病去世了。此后阿明一直独自住在房子里。他拿起电话打给了他的一位同母异父的哥哥。他的嫂子接了电话，立刻感觉到出了问题。
Armin admitted that he was in trouble with the police. Do you have a corpse lying in the cellar or something, his sister-in-law jokingly asked. He replied, No, in the freezer chest. She laughed, assuming he was joking. Armin then called the office where he worked as a computer technician. He told his boss that he needed to leave and that he might never come back. At 3.30 that afternoon, a call was placed to the Rottenborg police. The caller was Armin Mivus's attorney.
阿明承认他遇到了警察的麻烦。“你的地窖里是不是躺着一具尸体什么的？”他的嫂子开玩笑地问。他回答说：“不，在冰柜里。”她笑了，以为他在开玩笑。阿明随后给他的工作单位打了电话，他是一名电脑技术员。他告诉老板他需要离开，可能永远不会回来了。那天下午3点30分，罗滕堡警方接到了一个电话。打电话的人是阿明·迈维斯的律师。
He said that Armin was with him and was ready to make a full confession. Throughout his life, Armin Mivus sought gratification for his cannibalistic desires where he could. As a child, he'd watch his neighbors slaughter hogs for meat to sell. In his teens, he shadowed his friend to the butcher shop where he worked to observe him dismembering animal carcasses. It wasn't an unpleasant sight to Armin. He felt joyful to witness a once-living being serving a profound and important purpose. Whenever someone ate that meat, that animal was with them forever. He became more creative in his adult years.
他说阿明和他在一起，准备做出全面供述。阿明·迈维斯一生都在寻求满足他的食人欲望。小时候，他会看邻居屠宰猪肉出售。十几岁时，他跟着朋友去他工作的肉铺，观察他肢解动物尸体。这对阿明来说不是一种不愉快的景象。他感到高兴，目睹一个曾经活着的生命服务于一个深刻而重要的目的。每当有人吃那块肉时，那只动物就永远和他们在一起。他在成年后变得更有创造力。
He barbecued Barbie dolls and took delight in the way their plastic bodies melted and warped. He modelled limbs and organs out of marzipan before devouring them as if they were the real thing. He studied serial killer cannibals such as Jeffrey Dahmer and researched recipes ideal for human flesh. He constructed a cardboard diorama of a slaughter room before replicating it in the old smoke room upstairs. No one knew what stirred deep inside Armin Mivus's mind. He once told a schoolmate about his desire to eat human flesh, but they laughed in response, assuming he was making it up. Once Armin got a computer, he was able to indulge in his fantasy in new, shocking ways. He digitally altered images of men he had cut from pornographic magazines to appear butchered and bloodied.
他烧烤芭比娃娃，并对塑料身体融化和变形的方式感到高兴。他用杏仁膏塑造四肢和器官，然后狼吞虎咽地吃掉它们，就好像它们是真的一样。他研究了杰弗里·达默等连环杀手食人者，并研究了适合人肉的食谱。他制作了一个屠宰室的纸板模型，然后在楼上的旧熏制室里复制了它。没有人知道阿明·迈维斯内心深处在酝酿什么。他曾经告诉一个同学他想吃人肉，但对方笑着回应，以为他在编造。一旦阿明有了电脑，他就能够以新的、令人震惊的方式沉浸在幻想中。他用数字方式修改了从色情杂志上剪下的男人的照片，使他们看起来被屠宰和血淋淋的。
He did similar alterations to photos he took of himself. The internet led to Armin discovering that there were many others in the world that had the same morbid interests as him. In time, he became Frankie. The imaginary brother from his childhood had now become a digital persona he used to interact with other cannibal fetishists online. Many years later, he crossed virtual paths with a user named Kator. It wasn't until Kator lay drugged and bleeding in his slaughter room that Armin finally learned his real name. Many signals providing fast, effective pain relief for up to eight hours. Conquer headaches fast with the dual action pain fighting relief of new Advil Plus Acetaminophen, now available across Canada.
他对自己的照片也做了类似的修改。互联网导致阿明发现世界上有许多人有着和他一样的病态兴趣。久而久之，他变成了弗兰基。童年时代的虚构兄弟现在变成了一个数字人格，他用它在网上与其他食人恋物癖者互动。多年后，他与一个名叫卡托尔的用户在虚拟世界中相遇。直到卡托尔被下药并流血躺在他的屠宰室里，阿明才最终得知他的真实姓名。多种信号提供长达八小时的快速、有效止痛。用全新的Advil Plus Acetaminophen的双重止痛效果快速征服头痛，现已在加拿大各地上市。
Sleepyans were rare for Renee Yasnik. The 21-year-old baker was used to getting up early for work but a week-long holiday in early March 2001 provided him the opportunity to be lazy. Friday, March 9 marked the final day of said holiday and Renee wasn't planning on switching up his routine. He stirred at around 6.40am needing to use the bathroom and immediately afterwards, he slipped back into bed alongside his sleeping boyfriend, Björnt Branders. Renee didn't wake up again until almost three hours later. The remainder of his day would be spent relaxing at the apartment he shared with Björnt in the city of Berlin, Germany. Renee had the apartment all to himself as Björnt had already left for work. Later that night, Renee's feelings of relaxation had dissipated.
对于雷内·亚斯尼克来说，睡懒觉是罕见的。这位21岁的面包师习惯早起工作，但2001年3月初为期一周的假期让他有机会偷懒。3月9日星期五是该假期的最后一天，雷内没打算改变他的作息。他在早上6点40分左右醒来，需要上厕所，之后他立刻回到床上，躺在他熟睡的男友比约恩·布兰德斯身边。雷内直到近三个小时后才再次醒来。他的一天余下时间将在他与比约恩在德国柏林合租的公寓里放松度过。雷内独自一人在公寓里，因为比约恩已经去上班了。那天晚上晚些时候，雷内的放松感消失了。
It was nearing 7.40pm and Björnt was usually home by now. At first, Renee was annoyed. He thought Björnt had gone for an after-hours drink with some colleagues and not bothered to inform him. But by 10pm, Renee's irritation gave way to concern. Björnt was reliable and it was out of character for him not to contact Renee to let him know why he wasn't home on time. Strangely, not only did Björnt's mobile phone go unanswered but it continued to play an automated voice message that said, This connection is temporarily disconnected. When Björnt failed to come home that night, Renee spent the weekend reaching out to all of Björnt's friends and acquaintances trying to track him down.
时间接近晚上7点40分，比约恩通常这个时候已经到家了。起初，雷内很生气。他以为比约恩和同事去喝了下班后的酒，没费心通知他。但到了晚上10点，雷内的恼火变成了担忧。比约恩很可靠，不联系雷内告诉他为什么没按时回家是不符合他性格的。奇怪的是，不仅比约恩的手机无人接听，而且它还一直播放着一条自动语音信息，说：“此连接暂时断开。”当比约恩那天晚上没回家时，雷内整个周末都在联系比约恩所有的朋友和熟人，试图追踪他的下落。
No one had seen the 43-year-old. Renee called Björnt's office at the Technology Corporation where Björnt worked as a computer engineer. He was met with the answering machine. Björnt, it's Renee here, the machine recorded as Renee spoke pleadingly. I need to talk to you. I'm worried. Please come home. Whatever has happened, I'm sure we can work it out. Just come home. Please. Desperate for answers, Renee phoned Björnt's employer and was surprised to learn that Björnt had taken the Friday he disappeared off. He had told his supervisor that he needed to do so for personal reasons as there was something he wanted to take care of. He gave no other details.
没有人见过这位43岁的人。雷内给比约恩工作的技术公司打了电话，比约恩在那里担任电脑工程师。他遇到了电话答录机。“比约恩，我是雷内，”机器记录下雷内恳求的声音。“我需要和你谈谈。我很担心。请回家。无论发生了什么，我相信我们能解决。回家吧。求你了。”雷内急于寻找答案，给比约恩的雇主打了电话，惊讶地发现比约恩在他失踪的那个周五请了假。他告诉主管他需要这样做是因为个人原因，因为有些事情他想处理。他没有提供其他细节。
Renee was confused. Björnt had told him he was going into work on Friday. He even stated that he had a lot to do that day and would not be reachable on his mobile phone or in the office. Thursday night had passed normally, with no hints that Björnt was hiding something. When Björnt had left the apartment on Friday morning, he had taken his apartment keys, wallet and mobile phone. Renee was under the impression that he had indeed gone to work. Unable to uncover any clues as to where Björnt had really gone, Renee reported him missing to the police. He told them of their stable long-term relationship and of Björnt's commitment to his job. Although he worked a long hours, Björnt earned enough for them to live a good life together that was marred only by infrequent arguments over everyday problems.
勒内感到困惑。比约恩曾告诉他周五要去上班。他甚至说那天有很多事要做，手机和办公室都联系不上他。周四晚上过得很正常，没有任何迹象表明比约恩在隐瞒什么。周五早上比约恩离开公寓时，带走了公寓钥匙、钱包和手机。勒内以为他确实去上班了。由于无法找到比约恩真正去向的任何线索，勒内向警方报了失踪。他向警方讲述了他们稳定的长期关系以及比约恩对工作的投入。虽然比约恩工作时间很长，但他赚的钱足够他们过上美好的生活，唯一美中不足的就是偶尔会因为日常琐事争吵。
In recent months, Björnt had spent his work bonus to spruce up their apartment with expensive furnishings, and he and Renee had been eagerly planning an overseas holiday to take later in the year. Renee maintained that Björnt was happy and ruled out the possibility that he had gone somewhere to take his own life. Any hope that Björnt would resurface to attend a work conference on Monday March 12 was lost when he failed to show up for the event. Three days had now passed since anyone had seen or heard from him. He hadn't accessed his bank accounts over the weekend, nor had he used company funds which were also available to him. To those who knew Björnt, his sudden disappearance was perplexing. Police had a little luck locating him in the following weeks. With no word from his missing boyfriend, Renee Yesnick reached out to former journalist Nina Herrmann, who had previously worked for a local newspaper, hoping she could track Björnt down using her investigative skills.
近几个月来，比约恩用他的工作奖金添置了昂贵的家具来装饰他们的公寓，他和勒内一直热切地计划着今年晚些时候去海外度假。勒内坚称比约恩很幸福，并排除了他去某处自杀的可能性。任何关于比约恩会现身参加3月12日周一工作会议的希望，在他没有出席活动后彻底破灭了。距离上次有人见到他或听到他的消息已经过去了三天。周末他没有动用银行账户，也没有使用他可以动用的公司资金。对于认识比约恩的人来说，他的突然失踪令人费解。在接下来的几周里，警方几乎没有找到他的下落。由于失踪的男友杳无音信，勒内·耶斯尼克联系了曾为当地报纸工作的前记者尼娜·赫尔曼，希望她能利用自己的调查技能找到比约恩。
After questioning employees at Björnt's work, Nina made a small discovery. One of Björnt's colleagues had seen him on the morning of his disappearance at Bahnhof Zoo train station in Berlin. He thought nothing of the sighting as he knew Björnt took a train to work each day. Armed with a photograph of Björnt, Renee and Nina scoured the train station for clues and questioned staff, shop owners and travelers to determine where he might have gone to next. No one recalled seeing Björnt, so Renee posted his photo in the local newspaper, hoping that it would generate some leads. It didn't. He had seemingly vanished into thin air. In truth, he was bagged up in pieces at the bottom of Armin Mivus's freezer. Armin Mivus maintained that he didn't know Björnt Brandus was in a relationship when they met.
在询问了比约恩单位的员工后，尼娜有了一个小发现。比约恩的一位同事在失踪当天早上于柏林的动物园火车站见过他。他当时没多想，因为他知道比约恩每天都坐火车上班。拿着比约恩的照片，勒内和尼娜在火车站搜寻线索，并询问了工作人员、店主和旅客，以确定他接下来可能去了哪里。没有人记得见过比约恩，于是勒内把他的照片贴在当地报纸上，希望能提供一些线索。但并没有。他似乎凭空消失了。事实上，他被装在袋子里，分尸后放在阿明·迈韦斯的冰柜底部。阿明·迈韦斯坚称，他们见面时他并不知道比约恩·布兰德斯处于恋爱关系中。
In his confession, Armin said he knew very little about Björnt's personal life. Although Björnt as Kator mentioned having a friend, Armin didn't know that this person was a romantic partner with whom Björnt had lived with. In hindsight, it offered an explanation for a remark Björnt had made to Armin when they returned to Castle Wilhelmsfuhr train station following their failed first attempt at the slaughter. Describing his recollections from the station to author Gunther Stampf for his book Interview with a Cannibal, Armin explained that Björnt was intending to go home until he said, If I go back to Berlin now, I'll be facing a showdown. Armin queried the cryptic remark, but Björnt didn't elaborate. Could he have been agonizing over having to explain his abrupt disappearance to his boyfriend, Renee? It could have led to the unraveling of his double life, simultaneously ruining both.
在供词中，阿明说他对比约恩的个人生活知之甚少。尽管比约恩（化名卡托）提到过有一个朋友，但阿明并不知道这个人是与比约恩同居的浪漫伴侣。事后看来，这对比约恩在第一次屠宰尝试失败后回到威廉斯富尔城堡火车站时对阿明说的一句话做出了合理的解释。阿明在向作家冈瑟·斯坦普夫讲述他为《食人族访谈录》一书提供的回忆时解释说，比约恩本来打算回家，直到他说：“如果我现在回柏林，我将面临摊牌。”阿明询问了这句晦涩的话，但比约恩没有详述。他是否在为必须向男友勒内解释他突然失踪的原因而感到痛苦？这可能会导致他的双重生活崩溃，同时毁掉两段生活。
Author Gunther Stampf noted that Björnt faced a literal life or death impasse. Between returning home and slaughter, between reason and madness, Björnt chose death, slaughter and madness. The reasoning behind Björnt's decision, including why he sought to be eaten, died with him. He didn't pen a suicide note or record a goodbye message. Comments and behavior in the lead up to his fateful day ex were otherwise normal. Right before he left to meet with Armin Mivus, Björnt did a clean sweep of his personal computer, eradicating all trace of their communications. It was obvious that he didn't want anyone in his life to know about Ktor. Medical professionals retroactively examined Björnt's life to uncover what might have led him on his path of self-destruction.
作家冈瑟·斯坦普夫指出，比约恩面临着真正的生死僵局。在回家与屠宰之间，在理智与疯狂之间，比约恩选择了死亡、屠宰和疯狂。比约恩做出决定的背后原因，包括他为何寻求被吃掉，都随他而去。他没有写遗书，也没有留下告别信息。在那个决定性的一天之前，他的言行都很正常。就在他离开去见阿明·迈韦斯之前，比约恩彻底清理了他的个人电脑，消除了他们所有交流的痕迹。很明显，他不想让生活中的任何人知道“卡托”的存在。医学专家事后对比约恩的生活进行了检查，以揭示是什么导致他走上了自我毁灭的道路。
At age 5, Björnt's mother ended her own life. Björnt was forbidden to talk about her death to his father, and as an only child he had no one else to turn to. Their relationship soured from then onwards. Björnt's father was a cold tyrannical man who was never impressed by Björnt, despite his successes in life. By the time Björnt was an adult, the pair were practically estranged. Then, Björnt was cut off from his father's life entirely when he revealed he was in a relationship with a man. Doctors speculated that Björnt's masochism stemmed from feelings brought on by his father, either the hatred Björnt had for him, or the hatred Björnt had of himself as a result of his father's disapproval. Björnt's father was reluctant to speak about his son after learning what he had done.
5岁时，比约恩的母亲自杀了。比约恩被禁止向父亲谈论她的死，作为独生子，他没有其他人可以倾诉。从那时起，他们的关系就恶化了。比约恩的父亲是一个冷酷专横的人，尽管比约恩在生活中取得了成功，但他从未对儿子表示过赞赏。到比约恩成年时，两人几乎断绝了关系。后来，当比约恩透露他与一名男子有恋爱关系时，他与父亲的生活彻底切断了。医生推测，比约恩的受虐倾向源于他父亲带来的感受，要么是比约恩对父亲的仇恨，要么是比约恩因父亲的不赞同而产生的自我厌恶。比约恩的父亲在得知儿子所做的事情后，不愿谈论他。
In a brief conversation with a physician, he said that Björnt's childhood and youth development were uneventful. Björnt had a string of failed relationships both with men and women which linked to the overarching theme of rejection. Yet, there was nothing to prove that any of this was the catalyst for his actions. If he had any depressive moods or other mental disorders, Björnt hid them well. March 9 was not a significant date in his life, and the word kator wasn't found to be relevant either. The only person who could offer any true insight into Björnt's cannibalistic desires was the person who carried them out. Armin Mivus said being consumed was Björnt's ultimate ecstasy, his life goal. His death was his, quote, ultimate sexual climax.
在与一位医生简短的交谈中，他说比约恩的童年和青年发展都很平淡。比约恩有一连串失败的恋爱关系，无论是与男性还是女性，这都与拒绝这一主题有关。然而，没有任何证据表明这是他采取行动的催化剂。如果他有任何抑郁情绪或其他精神障碍，比约恩都掩饰得很好。3月9日在他生命中并不是一个重要的日子，“卡托”这个词也被发现没有关联。唯一能对比约恩的食人欲望提供真正见解的人就是执行这些欲望的人。阿明·迈韦斯说，被吃掉是比约恩最终的狂喜，是他的人生目标。他的死是他所谓的“终极性高潮”。
The slaughter didn't play out that way. Björnt didn't get to experience the euphoric feeling of being eaten alive that he had longed for. His day ex had ended disappointingly with him bleeding out in Armin Mivus' slaughter room. Dressing the wound did little to stem the flow, and Björnt was insistent that an ambulance not be called. He turned to Armin and said, As soon as I'm asleep, cut my throat. With a potent mix of blood loss, cold medicine, sleeping pills and alcohol impacting Björnt's body, Armin suspected he would pass out soon. Yet, half an hour later, Björnt was still awake. Armin, I'm so cold, he said, before requesting to be put in a warm bath to expedite his bleeding.
屠宰并没有那样进行。比约恩没有体验到他渴望的那种被活活吃掉的欣快感。他那决定性的一天以他在阿明·迈韦斯的屠宰室里流血不止而告终。包扎伤口对止血几乎没有作用，比约恩坚持不叫救护车。他转向阿明说：“我一睡着，就割断我的喉咙。”由于失血、感冒药、安眠药和酒精的混合作用影响着比约恩的身体，阿明怀疑他很快就会昏过去。然而，半小时后，比约恩仍然清醒。阿明，我好冷，他说，然后要求被放进温水浴中以加速流血。
Armin obliged. He removed Björnt's bandages as Björnt lowered into the warm water. Seeing the blood spurred from his open wound uplifted him. At this point, Björnt wanted to go to sleep in the bathtub and bleed to death. Armin went to his bedroom and read, stopping every quarter hour to return to the bathroom and check if Björnt had died. Two and a half hours passed and Björnt remained conscious. As Björnt went to lift himself out of the tub, he blacked out and his body crumbled to the floor. Armin began carrying Björnt's limp body back upstairs to the slaughter room, at which point Björnt stirred awake.
阿明照办了。当比约恩沉入温水中时，他拆掉了比约恩的绷带。看到鲜血从伤口喷涌而出，他感到振奋。此时，比约恩想在浴缸里睡着并流血致死。阿明回到卧室看书，每隔一刻钟就停下来回到浴室检查比约恩是否已经死了。两个半小时过去了，比约恩仍然有意识。当比约恩试图从浴缸里站起来时，他昏了过去，身体瘫倒在地板上。阿明开始把比约恩瘫软的身体搬回楼上的屠宰室，这时比约恩醒了过来。
With the sudden burst of energy, he tried to walk by himself. He believed that by doing so, his blood would flow out better and he would pass out faster. Then you can finally do it, he told Armin. Armin got Björnt back into the slaughter room and returned to checking on him every quarter hour. Then, at 3.30 am, he heard Björnt stirring about and went to see what he was up to. He found Björnt sprawled out on the floor. He had managed to pull himself out of bed, but had tripped over in the darkness. Armin roused Björnt, who remarked,
随着突然爆发的精力，他试图自己走。他相信这样做，他的血会流得更好，他会更快昏过去。“然后你终于可以做了，”他告诉阿明。阿明把比约恩弄回屠宰室，又回到每隔一刻钟检查他一次的状态。然后，在凌晨3点30分，他听到比约恩在走动，就去看看他在干什么。他发现比约恩瘫倒在地板上。他设法把自己从床上拉下来，但在黑暗中绊倒了。阿明唤醒了比约恩，比约恩说：
I've got to piss. Armin dissuaded Björnt from moving. If you stand up now, you'll be dead. You have no blood left in you. Delirious, Björnt insisted he needed to go to the toilet. He stood up, but within seconds his legs gave way and he fell to the floor. This time, Armin couldn't wake him. Armin donned a plastic apron. He placed Björnt's naked body on the table in the center of the room where he tied it down.
“我得去撒尿。”阿明劝阻比约恩不要走动。“如果你现在站起来，你就会死。你体内已经没有血了。”比约恩神志不清，坚持要上厕所。他站了起来，但几秒钟内双腿就瘫软了，摔倒在地板上。这一次，阿明无法唤醒他。阿明穿上塑料围裙。他把比约恩赤裸的身体放在房间中央的桌子上，并将其绑住。
After a farewell kiss and a brief prayer, Armin hesitated. The feeling passed quickly. He tilted Björnt's head slightly, then inserted a knife into his neck. It had been 10 hours since Björnt's ordeal had begun. When speaking of the killing to Orthogunterstaff, Armin recalled having an indescribable feeling of anger and joy at the same time. I hated myself for wanting to do it and I hated Björnt because he had come to me. On the other hand, I had an unbelievable feeling of happiness.
在告别之吻和简短的祈祷后，阿明犹豫了一下。这种感觉很快就过去了。他稍微倾斜了比约恩的头，然后将一把刀插入他的脖子。距离比约恩的磨难开始已经过去了10个小时。在向奥托·冈瑟·斯坦普夫谈论这次杀戮时，阿明回忆说有一种无法形容的愤怒和快乐同时存在的感觉。“我恨自己想做这件事，我也恨比约恩，因为他来找我。另一方面，我有一种难以置信的幸福感。”
It all went the way Björnt wanted. For years, Armin had studied medical textbooks and searched the internet for the ideal slaughter technique. Now, he put his knowledge into practice. After an hour of intense work, Armin switched his butcher's apron for a pair of pajamas and slept peacefully. The mutilation of Björnt's body continued the following day of Saturday, March 10. On Sunday, Armin sat alone at the end of his dining table. He had dressed it for the occasion with his finest tablecloth, a black porcelain dining set, polished cutlery and a glass of his favourite red wine. The table's centrepiece, a candelabra, created a warm ambience.
一切都按照比约恩想要的方式进行了。多年来，阿明研究了医学教科书，并在互联网上搜索了理想的屠宰技术。现在，他将自己的知识付诸实践。经过一个小时的紧张工作，阿明换下了屠夫围裙，穿上睡衣，安详地睡着了。对比约恩尸体的肢解在第二天，即3月10日星期六继续进行。周日，阿明独自坐在餐桌尽头。他为这个场合布置了餐桌，铺上了他最好的桌布，摆上了黑色瓷餐具、擦得锃亮的餐具和他最喜欢的一杯红酒。桌子的中心装饰品是一个烛台，营造出一种温暖的氛围。
On a plate before Armin was a piece of Björnt Brandis' upper back, cooked, seasoned and served with the sauce. As detailed in the book Cannibal by Lois Jones, Armin said a short prayer that ended. Lord God, thank you for providing me with a friend for life and for sacrificing Björnt's life on Earth for me. I hope I won't be lonely anymore. As Armin ate, he said, this is the most tasty meal I've ever had. Nothing is so delicious. His words were directed to Björnt's decapitated head, which Armin had positioned on the dining table next to him. He eventually buried Björnt's head in his backyard, along with Björnt's arms, legs and feet. In the months that followed, Armin ate 45 out of the 65 pounds of human flesh he had stored in his freezer.
阿明面前的盘子里是一块比约恩·布兰德斯的上背部肉，经过烹饪、调味并配上酱汁。正如洛伊斯·琼斯在《食人族》一书中所详述的那样，阿明做了一个简短的祈祷，最后说：“主啊，感谢您赐予我一位终身的朋友，并为了我牺牲了比约恩在地球上的生命。希望我不再孤独。”阿明吃着的时候说：“这是我吃过的最美味的一餐。没有什么比这更美味了。”他的话是对着比约恩被砍下的头颅说的，阿明把它放在餐桌旁。他最终把比约恩的头埋在后院，连同比约恩的手臂、腿和脚一起。在接下来的几个月里，阿明吃掉了他储存在冰柜里的65磅人肉中的45磅。
He even ate it at work in the form of rissoles, with his colleagues none the wiser. Armin believed that through this process, he was absorbing Björnt's characteristics and talents. Björnt had a decent grasp of the English language, and Armin felt his English speaking was improving with each meal. Despite having got exactly what he had wanted, Armin wound up back online, scrolling through cannibal forums as Frankie. Emboldened by having done what other users only fantasized about, Armin started bragging about his real-life cannibalism experience. He also posted gory pictures he had taken when he butchered Björnt's remains. Yet, his taste for human flesh had not been satisfied. 18 months after Björnt brandishes slaughter, Armin received an email.
他甚至在工作时把肉做成肉饼吃，同事们对此一无所知。阿明相信，通过这个过程，他正在吸收比约恩的特征和才能。比约恩对英语有相当不错的掌握，阿明觉得他的英语口语随着每一顿饭都在进步。尽管得到了他想要的一切，阿明最终还是回到了网上，以“弗兰基”的身份在食人论坛上浏览。由于做了其他用户只能幻想的事情而受到鼓舞，阿明开始吹嘘他现实生活中的食人经历。他还发布了他在屠宰比约恩遗体时拍摄的血腥照片。然而，他对人肉的胃口并没有得到满足。比约恩·布兰德斯被屠宰18个月后，阿明收到了一封电子邮件。
Someone had responded to his ad titled, Boys Sort for Butchering. It was a 23-year-old man from the Austrian town of Innsbruck, named Reinhold. From there, Armin Mivus' double life completely unraveled, leaving those who knew him as a seemingly harmless, friendly and helpful man, utterly shocked. Following Armin's confession, police returned to his Wusterfeld manner to undertake a more thorough search. Björnt's head and limbs were uncovered in the backyard, just as Armin had forewarned. Inside the house, officers discovered a collection of VHS tapes concealed in a bookshelf. What they contained caused many of those who watched them to seek psychological counseling. At just over eight hours long, Armin had videotaped everything that had occurred in the slaughter room between him and Björnt brandish.
有人回复了他那篇题为“寻找屠宰对象”的广告。那是一个来自奥地利因斯布鲁克镇的23岁年轻人，名叫莱因霍尔德。从那时起，阿明·迈韦斯的双重生活彻底崩溃，让那些认识他这个看似无害、友好且乐于助人的人感到无比震惊。在阿明供认后，警方回到了他的伍斯特费尔德庄园进行更彻底的搜查。比约恩的头颅和四肢在后院被发现，正如阿明预先警告的那样。在屋内，警官们在书架中发现了一系列隐藏的录像带。它们的内容导致许多观看的人寻求心理咨询。这些录像带全长超过八小时，阿明录下了他和比约恩·布兰德斯在屠宰室里发生的一切。
This included the severing of Björnt's penis, his eventual death, and the butchering of his remains. A meticulous record keeper, Armin had also kept copies of all the interactions he had online with Björnt brandish. There were pages upon pages of email and chat correspondence between the pair, in which they discussed the upcoming slaughter in gory and gratuitous detail. As the act of cannibalism was not a crime in Germany, lengthy deliberations were held to determine what exact charges Armin Mivus would face. Armin's attorney felt he should have been charged with killing on request, as Armin had acted only to fulfill Björnt's wish to die. The prosecution disagreed. While they accepted that Björnt's consent was a condition for his killing, it was not the motivating reason. They argued that Armin killed Björnt in order to butcher him and to satisfy his own fetish to consume male flesh.
这包括切断比约恩的阴茎、他最终的死亡以及对他遗体的肢解。作为一个一丝不苟的记录员，阿明还保留了他与比约恩·布兰德斯在线上所有互动的副本。两人之间有数页又数页的电子邮件和聊天记录，他们在其中以血腥和无端的细节讨论了即将进行的屠宰。由于食人行为在德国不是犯罪，因此进行了长时间的审议，以确定阿明·迈韦斯将面临的确切指控。阿明的律师认为他应该被指控为“应要求杀人”，因为阿明只是为了满足比约恩死亡的愿望而采取行动。检方不同意。虽然他们承认比约恩的同意是杀害他的条件，但这并不是动机。他们辩称，阿明杀害比约恩是为了屠宰他，并满足他自己食用男性肉体的癖好。
They sought a conviction based on the charge murder for sexual satisfaction. As per German law, in a criminal case involving the death of a person, the jury was composed of three professional judges and two members of the public. 71 seats in the public gallery were awarded at random by lottery, as citizens and journalists vied to witness the macabre spectacle in person. The trial itself began one year after Armin Mivus was arrested. A number of self-confessed cannibals gathered outside in support of Armin, with one telling a reporter, There are lots of us out there. We admire Armin because he had the guts to see this thing through. Armin appeared calm and collected in a suit and tie. One onlooker told a New York Times reporter that Armin looked like the nicest cannibal you could ever meet.
他们寻求以“为满足性欲而谋杀”的罪名定罪。根据德国法律，在涉及人员死亡的刑事案件中，陪审团由三名专业法官和两名公众成员组成。公众席上的71个座位是通过抽签随机分配的，因为市民和记者争相亲眼目睹这一恐怖的场面。审判本身在阿明·迈韦斯被捕一年后开始。一些自称食人族的人聚集在外面支持阿明，其中一人告诉记者：“我们外面有很多这样的人。我们钦佩阿明，因为他有胆量把这件事做到底。”阿明穿着西装打着领带，显得冷静而镇定。一位旁观者告诉《纽约时报》记者，阿明看起来就像你所能见到的最友善的食人族。
When Armin took the stand, he spoke for hours. At no point did he show any emotion or express any remorse. Show me the statute that says what I've done is against the law, he said pointedly at the prosecution. He reiterated that Björnt wanted to die and that he was merely assisting him. My friend enjoyed dying. For him it was a nice death. Björnt came to me of his own free will to end his life. I accept this is taboo, but I can justify what I did to God and the world. He denied killing Björnt for sexual satisfaction, saying, I didn't want to have sex with the partner I chose to slaughter. That had nothing to do with it. One has sex with a partner in bed, not with a piece of meat. It had nothing to do with sexual arousal.
当阿明出庭作证时，他讲了几个小时。他始终没有表现出任何情绪，也没有表达任何悔意。“给我看看哪条法律说我做的事情是违法的，”他尖锐地对检方说。他重申比约恩想死，他只是在协助他。“我的朋友享受死亡。对他来说，这是一个美好的死亡。比约恩是出于自己的自由意志来找我结束他的生命的。我承认这是一种禁忌，但我可以向上帝和世界证明我的行为是正当的。”他否认为了性满足而杀害比约恩，他说：“我不想和我选择屠宰的伴侣发生性关系。这与此无关。人们在床上与伴侣发生性关系，而不是与一块肉。这与性唤起无关。”
By eating, I wanted to make this person become part of me. At one stage, the courtroom was emptied so only the jury could watch the videos Armin had recorded of him and Björnt in the slaughter room. The footage had been heavily edited to remove imagery deemed too graphic, but what remained still greatly disturbed those who viewed it. Please do it this way, Björnt was recorded telling Armin. Get another knife. The footage conveyed what Armin had hoped. Björnt was a willing participant who prompted, consented and encouraged everything Armin did to him. But it also showed something that was not favourable to the defence. Analysis of the footage revealed Björnt was still breathing when Armin had killed him. Björnt's body was also shown to be restrained to the table, as if to keep him still.
“通过吃，我想让这个人成为我的一部分。”在某个阶段，法庭被清空，以便只有陪审团才能观看阿明录制的他和比约恩在屠宰室的视频。录像经过了大量剪辑，删除了被认为过于血腥的画面，但剩下的内容仍然让观看者感到极度不安。“请这样做，”录像中记录了比约恩告诉阿明的话，“拿另一把刀。”录像传达了阿明所希望的内容。比约恩是一个自愿的参与者，他提示、同意并鼓励了阿明对他所做的一切。但也显示了一些对辩方不利的东西。对录像的分析显示，当阿明杀害比约恩时，他还在呼吸。比约恩的身体也被显示被束缚在桌子上，仿佛是为了让他保持静止。
This contradicted Armin's testimony, in which he said he thought Björnt was dead before he inserted the knife through his throat. The nearly 500 emails and messages between Frankie and Kator were also read out to the court. These favoured the defence as it showed a, quote, willingness agreement between the two men, in which Björnt Brandus fully consented to being slaughtered by Armin Mithus. In his closing statement, Armin spoke of his correspondence with Austrian student Reinhold, which ultimately led to his arrest. If I hadn't been so stupid as to keep looking on the internet, Armin said, I would have taken my secret to the grave. Armin Mithus appeared at ease when it came time to hear the court's verdict. The preceding judge acknowledged that after viewing the slaughter video, it was clear that Armin took no pleasure in the actual killing of Björnt Brandus. He went on to say, Both Mithus and Brandus were looking for the ultimate kick.
这与阿明的证词相矛盾，他在证词中说他以为比约恩在把刀插入喉咙之前就已经死了。弗兰基和卡托之间近500封电子邮件和信息也被宣读给法庭。这些对辩方有利，因为它显示了两人之间存在一种“意愿协议”，其中比约恩·布兰德斯完全同意被阿明·迈韦斯屠宰。在结案陈词中，阿明谈到了他与奥地利学生莱因霍尔德的通信，这最终导致了他的被捕。“如果我没有那么愚蠢，继续在互联网上寻找，”阿明说，“我会把我的秘密带进坟墓。”当轮到听取法院判决时，阿明·迈韦斯显得很从容。主审法官承认，在观看屠宰视频后，很明显阿明在实际杀害比约恩·布兰德斯时并没有获得快感。他接着说：“迈韦斯和布兰德斯都在寻找终极刺激。”
This was an act between two extremely disturbed people who both wanted something from each other. The courtroom fell silent when the verdict was read. The judge explained that while Armin had committed a behaviour which is condemned in our society, there was an express request by Björnt Brandus to be killed. As such, the court found that what Armin had done was killing a person without being a murderer. Armin Mithus was convicted of manslaughter and sentenced to eight and a half years imprisonment. With good behaviour, he was up for release in under four and a half years. Despite receiving a somewhat favourable outcome, Armin Mithus appealed the verdict, insisting his actions fell under killing on request. He wasn't the only one to appeal.
这是两个极度不安的人之间的一种行为，他们都想从对方那里得到一些东西。当判决被宣读时，法庭陷入了沉默。法官解释说，虽然阿明实施了一种在我们社会中受到谴责的行为，但比约恩·布兰德斯明确要求被杀。因此，法院认定阿明的行为是“杀人而非谋杀”。阿明·迈韦斯被判过失杀人罪，判处八年半监禁。如果表现良好，他可以在四年半内获释。尽管得到了一个相对有利的结果，阿明·迈韦斯还是对判决提出了上诉，坚持认为他的行为属于“应要求杀人”。他并不是唯一一个上诉的人。
The state attorney was horrified by the light sentence and believed he should have been found guilty of murder. Fifteen months later, the initial trial's outcome was reversed. Armin Mithus was to be retried for murder. At the conclusion of Armin Mithus's retrial in May 2006, it was determined that the killing of Björnt Brandus did in fact fulfil all the requirements for murder. The court decided that Armin had motivating reasons that were in his self-interest to kill Björnt, namely sexual gratification. Therefore, it was not a one-sided mercy killing. The state prosecutor said, You wanted to record a film in your head, a hit film, a film you could play again and again so you could satisfy yourself sexually.
州检察官对轻判感到震惊，认为他应该被判谋杀罪。十五个月后，最初审判的结果被推翻。阿明·迈韦斯将因谋杀罪被重审。在2006年5月阿明·迈韦斯重审结束时，认定杀害比约恩·布兰德斯确实满足了谋杀的所有要求。法院裁定，阿明杀害比约恩有出于自身利益的动机，即性满足。因此，这不是单方面的仁慈杀戮。州检察官说：“你想在脑海中录制一部电影，一部热门电影，一部你可以一遍又一遍播放的电影，这样你就可以在性方面满足自己。”
Armin rebuked the decision, saying, It was not a sex thing. Every bite I took of him brought me closer to my brother. I wanted to eat him. I didn't want to kill him. In his final courtroom speech, Armin stated, I believe everyone should be able to decide what he wants to do with his own body. Armin Mithus was found guilty of murder and sentenced to life imprisonment.
阿明反驳了这一决定，说：“这不是性行为。我吃的每一口肉都让我离我的兄弟更近。我想吃他。我不想杀他。”在最后的法庭陈述中，阿明说：“我相信每个人都应该能够决定他想对自己身体做什么。”阿明·迈韦斯被判谋杀罪，判处终身监禁。
Armin Mithus's lawyer believed that the sentence handed down to his client was purposely excessive to deter any further aspiring cannibals to act on their impulses. Armin would later admit to author Gunther Stumpf that no punishment would have deterred him from slaughtering and eating Björnt Brandus, even the death penalty. Quote, The degree of punishment is unimportant. When someone like me has this desire and wants to carry it out, he'll go to any length to bring it about. I have had this desire with me for 30 years. Detectives have endeavored to track down all those who corresponded with Armin Mithus online to uncover a thriving cannibal network across Europe that Armin estimated had at least 800 members. Armin assisted the detectives who managed to identify 200 people and uncover several more possible cannibal killings.
阿明·迈韦斯的律师认为，对他当事人判处的刑罚是故意过重的，旨在阻止任何其他有抱负的食人者付诸行动。阿明后来向作家冈瑟·斯坦普夫承认，没有任何惩罚能阻止他屠宰和吃掉比约恩·布兰德斯，即使是死刑。他说：“惩罚的程度并不重要。当像我这样的人有这种欲望并想实现它时，他会不惜一切代价去实现它。这种欲望伴随了我30年。”侦探们努力追踪所有在网上与阿明·迈韦斯通信的人，以揭露一个遍布欧洲的繁荣食人网络，阿明估计该网络至少有800名成员。阿明协助了侦探们，他们成功识别了200人，并发现了更多可能的食人杀戮案件。
Many of those involved were highly educated individuals in successful, well-respected careers such as dentists, teachers and government officials. In 2004, Armin Mithus sued German heavy metal band Rammstein upon the release of their controversial single, Mindtile. Referred to as the cannibal song, Mindtile, which is slang for my penis, contained lyrics inspired by Armin Mithus' crimes. Considered one of the band's most notable live performances, Mindtile sees a band member performing in a giant cooking pot that is set alight by lead singer Till Lindemann, who dons a blood-stained chef's apron while holding a microphone with a large real knife attached to the end. Armin Mithus claimed the band had no right to make a song about his story without his permission. The suit never reached court. Armin was able to get a 2006 film based on his crimes, titled Rotenborg Butterfly, a grim love story, temporarily banned in Germany after complaining it infringed on his personal rights.
许多参与者都是受过高等教育的人，拥有成功且受人尊敬的职业，如牙医、教师和政府官员。2004年，阿明·迈韦斯在德国重金属乐队Rammstein发布其有争议的单曲《Mein Teil》后起诉了他们。《Mein Teil》被称为“食人歌”，其中包含受阿明·迈韦斯罪行启发的歌词。作为该乐队最著名的现场表演之一，《Mein Teil》中看到一名乐队成员在一个巨大的烹饪锅中表演，主唱蒂尔·林德曼点燃了锅，他穿着沾满血迹的厨师围裙，拿着一个末端连着一把真实大刀的麦克风。阿明·迈韦斯声称该乐队未经他的许可无权制作关于他故事的歌曲。诉讼从未到达法庭。阿明在抱怨2006年一部基于他罪行的电影《罗滕堡：蝴蝶，一个残酷的爱情故事》侵犯了他的个人权利后，成功地使其在德国被暂时禁映。
The ban was overturned in 2009 after Germany's Federal Court of Justice ruled that the producer's right to artistic freedom trumped that of Armin's personal rights. Recent reports state that Armin Mithus is a model prisoner, who is described by fellow inmates and guards alike as popular, friendly and polite. As a result, he is allegedly allowed to leave prison with two escorts and in disguise to wander around the local town. He also professes to have become a vegetarian. Armin applied for parole in 2017, but was unsuccessful. Further parole bids have been denied because of his poor social prognosis in the community and his lack of remorse for his actions. While Armin was diagnosed with schizoid personality by criminal psychologists, they have found him to have no signs of actual mental illness. A journalist for German newspaper Berliner Morgan Post once wrote of Armin Mithus.
禁令在2009年被推翻，德国联邦最高法院裁定，制片人的艺术自由权胜过阿明的个人权利。最近的报道称，阿明·迈韦斯是一名模范囚犯，被狱友和狱警一致描述为受欢迎、友好且有礼貌。因此，据称他被允许在两名护送人员的陪同下并乔装打扮离开监狱，在当地城镇漫步。他还声称自己已经成为一名素食主义者。阿明在2017年申请假释，但未获成功。由于他在社区的社会预后较差且对自己的行为缺乏悔意，进一步的假释申请都被拒绝了。虽然阿明被刑事心理学家诊断为分裂型人格，但他们发现他没有任何实际精神疾病的迹象。德国报纸《柏林晨邮报》的一位记者曾这样写道阿明·迈韦斯：
The one who listens to him learns a lot about loneliness and alienation, and about the dark side of an otherwise iridescent medium, the Internet. It is opening up so many opportunities, but at the same time, it is providing invisible accomplices in countless dark chambers. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“听他说话的人会学到很多关于孤独和异化的知识，以及关于一个原本绚丽多彩的媒介——互联网——黑暗面的知识。它开启了如此多的机会，但同时也为无数黑暗的密室提供了隐形的同谋。”感谢观看。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。